>> Chris: INTO NICE WHATEVER
HAPPENED TO SEGMENT, THOSE
MASSIVE SINKHOLES AND THE
FAMILIES WHOSE HOMES WERE
SWALLOWED UP, ADRIAN COLLINS
ASKED ON FACEBOOK, WHAT IS THE
UPDATE OF THE SINKHOLES IN
AMERICA?
ARE THEY BEING FILLED IN OR WHA
WHAT?
CORRESPONDENT PHIL KEATING
LOOKED AT THE SPECTACLES IN THE
SCIENCE BEHIND THE SINKHOLES.
>> THERE IS A SINKHOLE RIGHT
NEXT TO OUR NEIGHBORS HOUSE.
IT’S LITERALLY EATING THE HOUSE
COMPLETELY.
>> JUST MINUTES LATER, THE FIRST
HOUSE FELL INTO THE STILL
GROWING SINKHOLE.
>> IT TOOK THE SIDES OF THE
GROUND AWAY.
IT WAS ALIVE.
>> RAN DOOR-TO-DOOR COLLATING
STOMACH ALERTING THAT THEIR
LIVES AS THEY KNEW THEM WERE
DISAPPEARING DANGEROUSLY FAST.
>> IT’S LIKE QUICKSAND.
>> WITHIN TWO HOURS, TWO HOMES
WERE FOUND.
EIGHT OTHERS WERE COMING DOWN,
INCLUDING HIS.
LEAVING THE LAKEWOOD
NEIGHBORHOOD WITH A SINKHOLE
SMACK IN THE MIDDLE OF THE ROAD.
>> WE DIDN’T LOSE THE HOUSE, BUT
WE LOST THE HOUSE.
WE CAN’T LIVE HERE.
AND WE PROBABLY WON’T BE ABLE TO
LIVE HERE AGAIN.
>> YOU ARE GRABBING YOUR PETS
AND KIDS, DON’T HAVE MUCH TIME
TO GET ANYTHING.
>> THE UNIVERSITY OF
SOUTH FLORIDA USES VIRTUAL
REALITY MAPPING FOR SINKHOLES,
RIGHT
RIGHT IN THE AREA KNOWN AS
SINKHOLE ALLEY.
>> IT COULD BE TERMINATED AS IF
SOMEWHERE IN FLORIDA.
WE HAVE HURRICANES AND
SINKHOLES.
WE LIVE ON SWISS CHEESE,
ESSENTIALLY.
>> FLORIDA LEADS THE NATION IN
SINKHOLES WERE INSURERS PAY OUT
ABOUT A QUARTER BILLION DOLLARS
PER YEAR IN SINKHOLE CALAMITIES.
BUT MUCH OF THE COUNTRY IS ALSO
AT RISK.
SINKHOLES HAPPEN WHEN THE GROUND
UPON WHICH WE LIVE SITS ATOP
POROUS ROCK, LIKE LIMESTONE,
WHICH SLOWLY GETS EATEN AWAY BY
THE UNDERGROUND AQUIFER.
WHEN A ROCKETS TO WEEK, IT
CRUMBLES INTO THE WATER WITH
EVERYTHING ABOVE IT SINKING DOWN
WITH IT.
>> HOW DO WE PREVENT THIS FROM
HAPPENING?